Speaker 1: Let's chat with folks from the
audience. We are going to take some calls at
David Pakman dot com slash discord. That's how we
always take calls. And I want to start today with
Jack from Atlanta. Jack, welcome to the program.
Speaker 4: Ed, David, appreciate you having me
on. So I want to get straight to the point.
We've seen the GOP's disappointing performance
across the country in many areas. Well, they
still did pretty good in Florida. I'm going
to ask the one question on everyone's mind
Will Ron DeSantis be the GOP 2024 nominee?
Speaker 1: I have no idea. Personally, I
think, you know, we we first don't even know
whether he's running. But there is definitely a
shifting sense that DeSantis is increasingly the
leader of the Republican Party. And there are
sort of two data points for that. Number one,
Trump's picks, the country, you know,
the contested ones. It's easy to pick 50
incumbents and get almost all of them right. But
Trump's controversial picks, the contested picks,
Oz lost, Mastriano lost. Herschel Walker. We're
still counting ballots, almost certainly going
to a runoff. Blake Masters, losing Kerry Lake
County, okay, etc.. He doesn't make a big deal
out of endorsing DeSantis on the day before the
election. He goes, Yeah, yeah, reelect the Santos.
And then it's DeSantis who overperformed by seven
points and wins by 19. So there is clearly a
shifting wind. We're hearing from some Republican
insiders that they say this is the opportunity
to dump Trump. And the betting markets have now
shifted such that Ron DeSantis is favored in the
betting markets to be the Republican nominee.
So without injecting my personal opinion,
just going into the facts, it does seem as
though if both the Santos and Trump run, it's
not a given that this nomination goes to Trump
and this could make it a very crazy two years.
Speaker 4: Oh, I agree. It's going to be one
heck of a ride. So thank you very much, David.
Speaker 1: My pleasure. Jack from
from Atlanta. Great to hear from you.